be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books
so what I wanted to do here is have a
discussion on the death of the Silver
Surfer or as is more commonly known
Silver Surfer Requiem and what I'm
hoping is that by the end of this video
you'll understand why I consider this to
be one of the most beautifully written
stories in the history of Marvel Comics
so much like the story of Robert
Reynolds the century or Hulk the end the
Silver Surfer Requiem has this feeling
of both nostalgia and melancholy as if
the conclusion of the story leaves you
with this feeling that you've lost
something personal that you can't get
back
written by J michael Straczynski and
john by assad Rubik the Silver Surfer
Requiem is a story that's considered
standalone that is to say it's isolated
from any events taking place in the
Marvel Universe at the time while
previous stories involving the Silver
Surfer gave us various narratives
containing the surfers philosophical
thoughts on life and everyone's place in
it while simultaneously I guess
remaining detach from these things this
story moves us away from this sentiment
placing the surfer himself in the focal
lens of the question what happens when a
being is faced with their own mortality
and so the story initially picks up with
the Fantastic Four as they go about
their daily business and while Reed is
tending to his various mechanisms the
group is suddenly met with the arrival
of the Silver Surfer while J michael
Straczynski leaves a lot of things
ambiguous here what seems to be
happening is that a discussion is taking
place between Reed sue and the surfer
prompting Susan storm to burst into
tears and for Reed to attempt to cancel
the surfer at this point the story
transitions to Reed's lab where several
experiments are being performed over the
course of several days in order to
verify the request of the surfer himself
now while the tests of Reed Richards
seem to come back ominous in the sense
that he tells the surfer there's nothing
he can do the reason for the surfer
visiting Reed and the first place is
revealed when we're told that the silver
layer protecting the surfer from the
various forms of cosmic radiation is
deteriorating and that the Silver Surfer
is dying now we're not told exactly how
the radiation is killing the surfer I
would go as far as to submit that the
radiation is most likely caused some
form of cancer but following this
revelation the surfer informs Reed and
Susan that he wants to spend the
remaining time he has left traveling
around the planet Earth and then
ultimately traveling back to his home
planet of zenn-la from here we join the
Silver Surfer as he meets with
spider-man in what I consider to be one
of the best moments of the entire story
what bubble does here is provide this
kind of underlying question from so many
fans of the Marvel Universe in the form
of the surfers curiosity about humanity
what the Silver Surfer says is that he
considers planet or his adopted home it
was here that he rediscovered himself
and helped Fantastic Four defeat
Galactus and it was here that he met
various individuals that he would later
call allies and while he wants to
provide some kind of gift to the planet
that he loves so much he finds himself
confused about people in general what
the surfer says is that all people are
fundamentally the same that we drink the
same water and we eat the same food and
we have the same hopes and we train the
same dreams but despite all of this we
go out of our way to kill one another
over both large and small
things the surfers reason for visiting
Peter Parker is revealed here when he
says that after pondering these concepts
that with Peter Parker being human
himself perhaps he could provide some
measure of insight into how to fix these
problems if Peters response however is
that this is the reason why they fight
one villain at a time while society has
its share of problems relating to apathy
and violence there's also a societal
standard on what makes someone good or
bad as Peter states it's one thing to
stop a bad guy from doing evil when they
can agree on what evil is but it's
something else entirely to try to change
how people are
now the conversation between the two
begins to shift however when Peter
vocalizes a question that many casual
Marvel comic fans had been asking for
quite some time why is it that the
Silver Surfer uses the surfboard the
circle replies here that he doesn't use
a surfboard and that because he doesn't
need sleep or any nutritional sustenance
he simply needs a method of being
transported from one location to the
next while he offers Peter the
opportunity to have a portion of the
power cosmic and experience traveling
the spaceways for himself
Peter declines but requests that Mary
Jane Watson gain the experience instead
when Mary Jane returns from her journey
after about an hour or so she expresses
a deep gratitude to the surfer revealing
Peter Parker's reason for asking to let
Mary Jane have a portion of the power
cosmic what Peter tells us is that she
was designed to be a test subject of
sorts in that for the people of Earth to
truly move beyond their current state
they have to be made aware of what they
could achieve bestowing the power cosmic
on the Earth's population for five
minutes the whole of humanity gains its
first glimpse of awareness on a cosmic
level now one of this uh sure's in a new
era of peace for the planet Earth is
unknown but the story continues as the
Silver Surfer meets with dr. strange
what dr. strange tells us is that during
Reed's tests on the Silver Surfer over
the course of several days that he had
sent this information to Marvel's top
minds including dr. doom Professor
Xavier magneto and others and that while
they had all pulled their collective
efforts none of them were able to save
the surfer in response Doctor Strange
presents the surfer with the best gift
he can think of which is the history of
humanity split into two parts everything
prior to the arrival of the Silver
Surfer and everything after what dr.
strange says is that the silver surfers
arrival provided the Earth's population
with the knowledge that there is a much
larger universe out there with treasures
more beautiful that can be imagined and
with dangers that could threaten all of
existence but because of the silver
surfers arrival on the planet Earth
Doctor Strange and others for
to take part in these experiences a gift
that he perceives could never truly be
repaid at this point the story shifts to
the Super's arrival on zenn-la but due
to his weakened state he finds himself
crash-landing after waking up he
realizes he is in one of the hospitals
alongside shala ball the woman that he
loves over the course of the next
several days
while the scientists as in law try to
find a way to cure the surfer of his
illness they find that they're
ultimately unable to but as a surfer
rest on his deathbed zenn-la is met with
the arrival of Galactus now while the
surfers initial thought is that Galactus
has come to consumes in law Galactus s
wages is concerned by stating that the
surfers condition became known to him
very recently and that while Galactus
himself possesses a great amount of
power what he does not possess is the
power to save the surfer
what like two says is that despite any
of the previous conflicts the two of
them have shared that calacas does
always consider the Silver Surfer to be
the most honorable man he had ever met
and urges the surfer to let go of his
need to live and to be at peace which
ultimately allows a silver surfer to
finally die
now following his death the silver
surfers funeral lasts three days during
this time individuals from all over
zenn-la arrived to pay their respects
being bestowed with something referred
to as the marker of Noren as explained
to us anytime a person with this mark
finds himself or herself being enraged
the mark will change colors reminding
them that the sacrifice of the Silver
Surfer went to make them better people
furthermore is revealed to us that at
the request of Shelley ball Galactus had
used the remains of the Silver Surfer to
form a star viewable from the skies as
in law so that its people will always
remember the sacrifice of the Silver
Surfer so following the release of
Silver Surfer Requiem while this story
never broke the top 40 list and with
each issue only selling around 60,000
copies this story like so many others
that followed this line of storytelling
was met with universal acclaim
individuals who had followed the
exploits of the Silver Surfer over his
publication history and even those who
didn't found the story to be both
beautifully written but sad at the same
time websites like Goodreads IGN and
county book roundup considered it to be
one of the greatest achievements in the
career of J michael Straczynski falling
in line with some of the best stories in
his lifetime including his 2001 run of
spider-man and Superman the earth 1
series
with that being said we're going to go
ahead and bring this video to an end I
hope you guys enjoyed it and I will
catch you guys later please